hi let's start with the chart this is an
measles epidemic it looks like this is a
chart from Israel although most is now
suffering from that and as you can see
this charge of the spike and then going
down this is about 4000 measles cases in
Israel around between 2010 2019 and just
the tube it's actually an epidemic and
them in an outbreak well this is how it
looked like ten years before so we had
4,000 cases in around and the ten years
before that didn't have like even a
thousand so this is an outbreak and
that's a problem and as you can see also
in Europe specifically in Poland this
happens like measles is now around the
world but yet those cases are like a
fraction of what we used to have thirty
years ago 50 years ago so we ask
yourself the question what changed and
the answer is vaccines and is it that
simple
well yes but actually no so given a
graphics into one person that's easy but
vaccinating an entire population that's
pretty hard because you have to ask
yourself some questions like on which
ages do we give the people the vaccines
how many because some some is not enough
like if you give you know measles in aid
for at least four vaccines when when a
child is born but not immediately when
they're born just after one year so some
is not enough but then maybe some is too
much and for that we need disease
modeling so this talk is disease
modeling with Syfy and time see this is
me my first time speaking not in my
country Israel so thank you for
welcoming here me here my grandfather
was born in Poland so this is kind of a
nice place to be
to have the first time I work in a
centenary one it's a cyber security
company in Israel this is not related to
what I'm going to talk about I'm also
volunteering in an organization called
data hack which is a
nonprofit for the advancement of data in
Israel and my talk is about disease
modeling which was my master's thesis in
the university also build a website
called epidemics over here which shows
you how different diseases progress in
Israel and let's start just got this
talk is gonna have six parts I'm going
to show you what's a dynamic model
because the disease model is a specific
kind of a dynamic model so the second
part would be disease models then I'm
gonna learn a bit about MCMC maybe we'll
skip that in the rash because I'm not
sure we have enough time then you're
gonna see how we take the model that
we've built and used the MCMC to fit it
to data that we already have from the
Israeli Ministry of Health then I'll
show you why we need it because we need
it in order to simulate future
possibilities and realizations of the
futures in order to understand different
policies what what's the effect of
different policies in the future
then because you're gonna see some toy
examples it's not gonna be that
interesting we're going to show you I'm
going to show you the results of like
real research using those methods let's
start with a dynamic model who's done
dynamic models and specifically in
Python one person cool so a dynamic
model is basically what you see up top
you have some groups in the population
and they interact with each other so
let's say kids they become adults adults
become mature the mature people can die
the kids can be born and the adults can
make new kids so those arrows actually
define how the system behaves and
specifically let's say you can say now
you're gonna try and see so you look at
the system over time and you can say
maybe the kids at time point seven let's
say at time point is one year the kids
at time point seven is and how many
adults you have in the population time
that with the average kids per person
and may but don't forget that some of
them get like they get adult they they
age so they get into the adult group so
you can say that the kids at time seven
and
it's a function of adults and kids at
times six and basically you need to
start with like the state zero so you
say that I invented that some of them
like a hundred eight hundred and a
hundred kids adults matures so that's
the what we call state zero then you
have the rates like when child becomes
adult so you say in age twenty-one so
every year one divided by twenty one
people become adult and so on and so
forth so we have the rates and now all
you need to do is a Python loop you take
each time point out of let's say for
eighty years and you say well this time
point is a function of the time points
before then and basically now you have
vectors and you can try and graph those
vectors and you can see that that so in
the top part you have the Sam so you see
that more people being born than they
died so all the groups go up and then
the bottom chart you can see like the
normalization of that so you can see
that there are more kids and more mature
people as we progress and eventually it
goes into what we call the steady state
and this is how the population looks
like if nothing changed so what's the
disease model disease model is basically
a type of a dynamic model but instead of
talking about ages we're talking about
disease progression so some people can
be susceptible to the disease that means
that they are not currently sick but
they could become sick because they
haven't yet then if they got infected we
come into the infected group and once
they recover they go into the recovered
group and on the most basic model that's
the most basic model of disease modeling
after we become recovered let's say in
chickenpox you can't go sick again
that's a nice disease to have and also
you have now the state zero and now you
have the recovery rate you have all the
rates one of them would be the recovery
rate so that's easy we can see about the
disease we can say how how long does it
take to recover from it so that's an
easy rate to have and then you have beta
which is the force of infection
so this says if I'm meeting an infected
person how is it is for me to get
infected and each vaccine has their own
unique beta but what is this better so
this is now our little secret
this is a magic number called force of
infection we're gonna what you're going
to do is later we're gonna see what beta
is that's what we're going to fit to the
data and get a distributions of beta and
basically you have the same now instead
of talking about discrete time points
let's say those are derivatives so the
derivative of s at time T is some
function of s and I and our and instead
of using a loop to solve that you're
gonna have we're going to have the state
zero and rates but instead of having the
loop to solve that we're defining the
function as a function that receives
time points and the vectors that were
interested in and then we use sy PI to
solve that so that basically it's a
differential equation model and scifi
solves that for us what cipher is gonna
give us so you see the salt is the
function Sol and what's what cipher is
gonna give us is this object that one of
it is the vectors of the solutions so
this is not very interesting what's
interesting is when you wait chart that
and you can see the disease so now
that's the pretty interesting part you
can see that disease if you look closely
started with like one person sick out of
ten million but the disease was pretty
strong so infected people very quickly
so this is the sick people are the red
line many of them got sick very fast
then most of the population were already
sick and recovered and we could we said
that you can't get sick again
so again it went down very fast and now
most of the population was sick some at
some point in history but now the
population is pretty healthy so that was
a nice disease a worse disease would be
that if you recover you maybe you're
immune for the disease for a bit but
then you can become sick again and then
we can write again
the model so again we define some parts
and then we define the function just
instead of not returning this we have
the minus gamma R so the gamma R is the
rate in which will become susceptible
again and then we solve that and we can
plot that and now we can see that the
disease is not going down to zero it's
still not very strong because it's not
an epidemic it's still lower than the
susceptibles and it recovered but you
can state that at each time point so it
basically becomes a steady state or each
pipe Oh itch time point about half a
percent of the population is sick in
this specific disease in Israel it means
that at each time boat about 30,000
people are sick let's say the floor
stuff like that important it would mean
times 5 that because the population
ratio so imagine 150,000 people have the
flu at each time that you're looking so
what's MCMC you can now take all the the
two parts before then keep them in mind
but you could not going to need it for
this part MCMC is a method that we have
in order to find distributions of
parameters so basically it relies on
Bayesian on the Bayesian formula this is
what's called Bayesian this is one of
the ways to fit Bayesian models into
data so basically we want to ask
yourself let's say let's start with the
is the example that would be a linear
model right we want to ask yourself this
those those points I can tell you that I
simulated them so they come from I think
three X plus four but we're gonna ask
what's the chance did they come from 2x
plus five right so given the data I
think a is 2 B is five what's probably
of that well we don't know that what we
do know is that if the mother was in
fact
what's the chance that we got the data
so we flipped that using the Bayesian
formula the thing is we need now two
other thing what's the probability of a
equals two and B equals five somewhere
in the universe and what's the
probability of the data two terms that
I'm not actually you don't even have the
words to understand what they actually
mean the thing is we're not gonna need
them eventually what we gonna what we're
gonna do is that now we have two
competing offers we can say which one of
them is more likely no that's nice
because the P of the data I will that
cancels each other out and also the the
second part this is actually
mathematically not cancelling each other
out for this talk let's say they do
cancel each other out
the best part will always be the same so
what we're left here is what the
probability of the data of the data
given one model it was a probability of
data given a second model and in this
specific point we can say that the left
part is larger so now I'll remember we
have two different competing options one
of them is better if it's better great
let's let's look for another one that's
maybe even better if it's if it's worse
than not our candidate offer well let's
skip it but not like skip it all the way
maybe on some events maybe also try it
and explore the space so basically what
you're doing we're doing MCMC we're
exploring the space giving this formula
and eventually we can see that we're
exploring the space and we get options
for a and B and you can see that the
simulated offer was a three X plus four
so the model found that this was the
most most highest density of the of the
searching the parameter space but we can
also see a distribution so now you're
gonna ask yourself well we know you know
linear models why just not just find the
two points and it's probably correct for
linear models but this is a good a good
example for learning
what you can see now is that you have a
parameter space that how like a and B
are acting together and this is the
solution that the model finds so it's
pretty much close so this how it was
defined and this is how you do it you
define two like two parameters up top
then you only tell the package you tell
PMC well Y hat is how we define it's
basically a wiener linear model of a and
B then you tell PI MC where now sample
search the space basically and this is
gonna take a little bit of time because
it's now sampling the space and return
us a results right because we have now a
distribution so those are the marginal
distributions of a and B and it says
well I'm two for sorry as close to 3 and
B is close to 4 and well this this
drying gives us the also the Sigma like
the variation of the data and from
simulating it and tell you also that
this is close so yes great success the
beautiful thing about Bayesian modeling
is now that you told me right two
minutes ago you told me we don't need it
for a linear model and I'll tell you
that's correct but once you have a bit
more of a complex model instead of
starting to look for like different
models that try and predict like a
cosine function or maybe something with
many like powers and stuff like that you
can just you can do everything you've
done the same you define a PI MC model
and then you just tell it well the
formula Y hat is not a X plus B it's a X
plus B and the cosine of something and
then you just tell it will sample this
and give me the results and then when
you sample this you get the Sigma and
you get the parameter
and you can see that it's pretty close
to what we simulated before them you can
also do an outlier removal so the way we
did the linear model we try to predict
it we said that the error is normal so
now let's let's tell it the error is not
being it's not from the normal
distributions from a student t-test
distribution and if you know that you
know it's more forgiving for mistakes
let's call it again not mathematically
official but it's not bad so then you
can see that the model when you're
trying if you have an outlier here like
up top and you give it the normal
distributions that give you a bad result
but if you're trying to predict it with
the statists with a student T
distribution
well now you can see that the yellow
line which became from the student T
simulation is a lot closer to the
simulated line so again we did we only
change like one line of code and now
again now it predicts it beautifully and
that's it that's basically MCMC it's it
is searching the space with some
probabilities and eventually gives you a
distributions of parameters let's talk
about model fit so now you have data
specifically we had data from the
industry industry Israeli Ministry of
Health and it looks like that and we
want to predict that well we can try to
predict some model that comes from a
formula but we want to do something more
we actually have a disease model so what
I showed you earlier when you go into
real-life basically the models are more
complex and they look something like
this you have the susceptible population
but also you can choose maybe vaccinate
maybe not if you do on which ages stuff
like that and then you have the rates
the parameters are by what basically are
the rates the rates were before then and
you define the model we did that part
there are only things that we don't know
and I told you well this is our little
secret is the
we have some magical number that is
called the force of infection it
basically says how large how infectious
is the disease right everything else we
can't we got from clinical trials so but
now we have a tool to solve that right
we have them same support so if we have
data and we have MCMC let's just take
the model well let's define all the
parameters that we don't know one of
them would be the only one would be beta
now let's say that Y hat being come
instead of being a linear model or some
formula it's a black box a black box
that tells us this is how the disease
looks like and then we can simulate it
the way we did this before but you also
know how the black box looks like and
the black box is a disease model in the
shape of different differential
equations that are solved with scifi so
you know everything in that part you
have the data you have the MCMC you have
the SyFy now you just need to actually
run it and MCMC it tells you what the
beta is the modal point would be one
point 42 but then it's because it's
coming from this distribution so great
we actually predicted what we wanted to
predict and we can look in the disease
and say well this is close to the data
but you ask yourself why why do I need
this beta give me predictions and what
what I'm gonna say is that this this
type of work is not trying to predict
I'm not trying to predict if the amount
of sick people in ten years is gonna be
a thousand or 2,000 those models are not
good for that what I do try to predict
is if I'm gonna tell you vaccinate
children instead of at the age of two
vaccinate them at the age of three which
one of them is gonna have less sick
people in the entire population so we
have the beta so in order to do that we
need to actually simulate the future
possibilities we have to simulate one
option with vaccinated kids to one
option with similar I think with
vaccinating kids at three
and this is the simulation part so when
we have a simulation we actually need to
search the space but we're searching a
space that is not known but for this we
have the distribution of the beta so we
can X we can ask yourself two competing
models one of them like we had a disease
we ran the disease for a few years we
got the distributions of beta and now if
T like after 30 years so if T is larger
than 30 times 52 weeks then P becomes
new P the thing is what's the new P so
we have two options where new P could be
one and new P could be like 0.5 and then
I can run the model right because here
we define the model that runs and
returns a result and for each
possibility we have now the solutions
from Sify which returns a vector and we
can pull out that vector and you can see
that the red option would be with the
new P so in P sorry I didn't say what P
is if P is trying to understand how many
people actually vaccinate so P was zero
because nobody was vaccinating in the
first 30 years and then you ask yourself
what's the option of people vaccinating
at the age of like all the population
100% of the population are vaccinating
and what's what what happens in the
option that half of the population is
vaccinating so that's basically P and
you can see that if the entire
population is vaccinating the amount of
sick people's is a lot less that's the
green one that would be a lot less than
the red line where half of the
population only vaccinates
so that was a simple example example and
you can see that maybe after knowing a
lot of dynamic models you can see that
well that's not surprising if you have
less people vaccinating this it means
more sick people so the more interesting
examples would be what happens we do
have a real disease so in my mother's
master Steve is thisis this was the real
model so we had a model that looked like
this but also it had
age groups so imagine that we have those
six compartments and we can ask it at
each point we can say well if the year
is more than 57 we got this type of
vaccine but then after 2002 they changed
the vaccine to a different type of
vaccine what happens when you change
when you change the vaccine type and
then you can you can become two types of
infected some people feel the disease
and actually they stay at home so they
have a strong disease but they stay at
home and some people get a little bit of
the bacteria but they they don't feel it
so do we go to work so they could be
more infectious because they actually
meet people so what's more infectious
well that depends on how much and other
such a sociological factors and so we
have all the parameters but still we
don't know beta the thing is beta is not
a color scaler anymore it's it's like a
vector because it each it each age also
the disease could behave differently for
different people so beta is not just one
number it's like the amount of age
groups that we have and also we're going
to ask yourself like if I'm 30 you
what's the chance of me meeting a person
that's also 30 or what's the chance of
me meeting a person that's 20 and this
matrix says that so you can see that
kids made it meet each other a lot but
they also meet people that are like 25
30 because that's are probably those
their parents but you can see that
basically we meet people our own age so
infect people that are our own age and
this force of infection thing it's no
longer a number it's not longer a vector
it's basically functions that a function
that says how am i infecting depending
on who I meet what time of year is this
because maybe the the bacteria itself
behaves differently in winter or in
summer and that's basically become now
instead of one number that we need to
predict using MCMC we're trying to
predict about seven numbers and those
are some results with the red ones are
actual data from
Israel of people being sick in specific
disease that's called pertussis and the
prediction that we had like the defeat
that we got from the MCMC is the black
line with more realization of the
simulation in the gray lines and then we
can ask us that we simulated different
futures and what we asked himself was
let's change the age of the vaccines so
now the kids are getting a vaccine at
the age 5 and at the age of 7 so at the
left part you can say well I'm going to
ask yourself what happens if we
vaccinate them instead that 13 and 18 or
it's 6 and 10 and the more left you go
those are less sick people and the more
right you go those are more so when the
red parts you can say what we if we take
one book is enough maybe we don't need
that maybe we can vaccinate the kids
only at the age of 7 you can see that we
have a lot more people sick in the blue
parts you can say just take the 2 and
change the ages and then the yellow part
is a source of what we if we add another
vaccine so you can say that if we had
another vaccine well that's simple we're
gonna have a lot less sick people but
then other questions come to mind like
do we have the money for that
if if we can use the money for
vaccinating and against the floor
measles maybe that's better
so we sticked with let's keep all those
vaccines let's keep the two vaccines
let's just see if we can change the ages
and we can see that instead of
vaccinated kids at 5 and 7 we said it if
we vaccinate them on Ansari instead of 5
and 13 we vaccinate them instead of
vaccinating them on 7 and 13 we say
let's vaccinate them on 5 and 13 and
those were the best results sadly they
were not good enough in order for the
entire system to change its course we
got the results that we're gonna have 1
percent reduction in the disease but
then it would cost a lot of
and the entire system gonna need to be
changed because we take one vaccine and
instead of vaccinate the kids it's cool
they're gonna do this in the Cuban
Gardens so many other different problems
that we can't answer with Python so in
my specific case we it didn't become the
policy but that's how you do you look
for policies in pmc and scifi remember
that all models are wrong but some are
useful and in this specific case it's
actually correct because again we're not
trying to predict how many sick people
just what different policies are gonna
do in order to like how they're gonna
behave next to each other which is the
best policy
this is me you can welcome to my website
my facebook my github specifically dove
panda is a new open-source package that
I'm welcoming you to try it's gonna help
you write better pandas code thank you
[Applause]
thank you have a time for one question
maybe two oh there's one on the back hi
thank you for the talk I was just
curious for pi MC which I haven't used a
great deal the way you'd set it up I
mean you had a prior essentially a
linear model is it is it easy in this
package to set up multiple priors and
then search through multiple parameters
for different priors and maybe have
there's a terms of speed maybe have some
sir perilla sterilization framework in
place is that supported so again are you
heard like two questions so we is it
easy to paralyze it yeah so right now in
your models you assumed you had a
sinusoidal function in one and another
yet a linear function and you just you
searched over the parameter space but
let's say I don't know what the prior is
let's say I have no idea for a
particular dataset and I want to explore
a large universe of priors and see which
one fits is that possible I mean of
course you could set it up manually but
is there support in PI MC for through
automating this process so so what I had
was oh so I understand the questions I'm
not sure because what I used it's
defining the basic priors like let's say
a behaves like it it's redistribution as
its prior is normal and then this is the
model something with a sinus I'm not
sure if it can actually look for
different models I believe no but maybe
I'm wrong cuz my cuz the entire part
that you do in the disease modeling is
actually looking for what's the best
model but in disease modeling the model
is not a formula again so this is the
hard part actually trying to fit a model
into the reality so I'm not sure how
it's gonna look for different models but
maybe with easier models that are like
can be formulated into one formula maybe
it kid I'm not sure thank you
thank you so much crate up house please
[Applause]